what advice would you give to a young
person high school
college
about how to be successful
you've done a lot of incredible things
in the past decade
so maybe maybe of some
something there might be something there
might be something
i mean
it might sound like a
simplistic or so but i would say
literally just
follow your passion double down on it
and if you don't know what's your
passion just figure out what could be a
what could be a passion so this that
might be an exploration
when i was in elementary school was math
and chemistry
and i remember for some time i gave up
on math because
my school teacher she told me that i'm
dumb
and i i i guess maybe an advice would be
just ignore people if they tell you that
you're dumb you're dumb
you mentioned something offline about
chemistry and explosives
um
what was that about so let's see
so a story goes like that i can
i i got into chemistry maybe i was like
a second grade of my elementary school
third grade
uh i started going to chemistry classes
uh
i i really love building stuff
and
i did all the experiments that they
described in the book
okay you know how to create oxygen with
vinegar and
and baking soda so okay
so i did all the experiments
and at some point i was you know so
what's next what can i do
and uh
explosives they also it's like a you
have a clear reward signal you know if
the thing worked or not
so i remember
at first i got i got interested in
producing hydrogen that was kind of
funny experiment from school you can
just burn it and then i moved to
nitroglycerin so that's also relatively
easy to synthesize
i started producing essentially dynamite
and detonating with it with my friend i
remember there was a you know there was
at first i can maybe two attempts that i
went with a friend to detonate what we
built
and it didn't work out and like a third
time he was like ah it won't work like
let's don't waste time
and um now we were
i was carrying this uh
this
you know that tube with dynamite i don't
know pound or so
dynamite in my backpack or like a riding
on the bike to the edges of the city
[Laughter]
yeah and
attempt number three
this would be attempt to number three
attempt number three and
now we we dig a hole to
uh put it inside it actually had the uh
you know electrical detonator
we we draw a cable
behind the tree
i even i i never had i haven't ever seen
like a explosion before so i thought
that there will be a lot of sound
and but you know we're like a laying
down and i'm holding the cable and the
battery at some point you know it kind
of like a three to one
and
i just connected it and it felt like at
that ground shake it was like a more
like a
sound and then
the soil started kind of lifting up and
started falling on us yeah wow and then
uh now the friends said let's let's make
sure next time we have helmets
but also you know
i'm happy that nothing happened to me it
could have been the case that i i lost
the limb or so yeah but that's childhood
of an engineering mind
with a strong reward signal
of an explosion
i love it
my there's some aspect of uh chemists
the the the chemist i know like my dad
with plasma chemistry plasma physics he
was very much into explosives too
it's a worrying quality of
people that work in chemistry they love
i think it is that exactly is the the
strong signal that the thing worked
there is no doubt there's no doubt
there's some magic it's almost like a
reminder that physics works that
chemistry works it's cool it's almost
like a little glimpse at nature that you
yourself engineer i that's why i really
like artificial intelligence especially
robotics is you create
a little piece of nature
and in some sense even for me with
explosives the motivation was creation
rather than distraction yes exactly
you